[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors tu voir mots ce témoignage est
tout à fait banale de la souffrance
qu'induit le harcèlement alors le
harcèlement c'est quoi justement il peut
être vu d'abord défini comme étant une
pratique une pratique violente de la
même manière que peuvent l'être les
discriminations qu'elles soient d'ordre
sexuel ou sexistes on le voit à travers
cet exemple l'harcèlement peut se
caractériser par quatre grandes
dimensions
le premier va être sa fréquence on peut
tout à fait augurer que cette personne a
déjà connu des expériences de
l'harcèlement dans le passé avec tout le
traumatisme que ça peut avoir en dehors
du nombre de fois et puis également une
deuxième chose qui va être excessivement
importante va être la nature des faits
ce sont ce qu'on peut appeler des micros
violence qui ne seront pas forcément
perceptible par tous et par tout c'est
aussi pour ça que l'on l'appelle
d'ailleurs l'invisible visibilité parce
que c'est à la fois invisible pour
beaucoup de personnes nous retour mais
excessivement visible pour la victime
et puis il y a la question de
l'intensité on peut tout à fait
s'imaginer ici que les témoins sont
actives excessivement nombreux ils le
sont d'autant plus à l'ère du numérique
lorsque les auteurs sont également en
nombre
l'impact va être beaucoup plus important
d'autant plus quand la victime comme
c'est le cas ici est seul et n'ont pas
accompagné
et puis le quatrième raison des moindres
c'est l'oppression qui dit harcèlement
ne dit pas égalité entre les deux
personnes alors on est du point de vue
de la victime
s'il la victime se sont opprimés elle ne
peut pas répondre de manière forcément
entre guillemets approprié par rapport à
la situation
on le voit d'ailleurs dans des débats
télévisés ou une personne victime de
harcèlement peut parfois rire de manière
et par rapport à la scène et justement
c'est bien là toute l'importance
derrière ce jeu qui peut paraître
apparent se cachent des victimes des
victimes qui sont à la fois meurtri
blessé donc les impacts peuvent être de
plusieurs ordres
on l'a vu des stratégies d'évitement des
angoisses pour les jeunes filles pour
les femmes également
ça peut être des conduites anxiogène
dépressives voire à l'école des
situations extrêmes qui peuvent conduire
jusqu'au suicide
on le voit actuellement dans les
enquêtes qu'on mène sur le climat
scolaire les élèves victimes de
harcèlement à l'école banques
d'ailleurs tant leur souffrance est
importante et on y présente que tout le
monde ne voit mais ne fait rien tu as
raison johanna dans les enquêtes que
l'on mène que tu mènes sur le climat
scolaire
on le voit 10% des élèves chaque année
sont victimes de discrimination de
harcèlement alors ça veut dire quoi
cette affaire ça veut bien sûr dire que
le harcèlement l'opprobre les injures la
discrimination ça ne s'arrête pas à la
frontière de l'école à la grille de
l'établissement sa cour en dehors dans
la rue dans les transports publics mais
aussi sur internet dans les réseaux
sociaux facebook twitter et en retour
tout ce qui se passe sur twitter
facebook internet mais aussi la rue les
transports publics rentrer dans les
établissements scolaires alors face à ce
constat qu'est ce qu'on peut dire tout
simplement que la discrimination n'est
plus le fait de l'espace matériel ou de
l'espace numérique mais c'est tout
ensemble que la discrimination ou que le
harcèlement donne à voir
juridiquement la discrimination elle est
assez nettement défini 45000 euros
d'amendé trois ans d'emprisonnement on
le sait la discrimination ne passe plus
en droit même si dans les faits elle
perdure dire que la discrimination n'est
plus possible
ça signifie aussi de dire que l'injure
n'est plus possible et on sait sur quels
critères on et injuriée on est toujours
injurié sur des critères liés à la
discrimination sexisme homophobie liés
à l'apparence liées aux origines à la
religion réelle ou supposée
quand quelqu'un a subi le coup de
l'opprobre quand quelqu'un subi la
discrimination l'injure c'est toujours
quelque chose de l'ordre de la mise à
l'écart qui est en jeu alors on peut
aussi avoir une définition sociologique
et non pas juridique de la sphère en
disant par exemple que la discrimination
que les harcèlements et perfusé de
stéréotypes de représentation mais on
pourrait aussi avoir une lecture plus
historique de cette question en
soulignant le phénomène de sédimentation
progressive des stéréotypes et des
représentations discriminante à l'égard
des minorités alors en disant ça et ce
pourquoi on est là aujourd'hui c'est
pour souligner le fait que dans les
espaces privés dans les espaces publics
physiques ou virtuels aujourd'hui la
discrimination
l'injure le harcèlement ça a des
conséquences ça a des conséquences bien
sûr sur les victimes
ça a des conséquences bien sûr de
manière pénale sur les hauteurs mais ça
aussi on va le voir des conséquences sur
les témoins d'autant plus actuellement
ou comme je l'aï dit les témoins sont de
plus en plus nombreux à l'heure
d'internet où justement quelques clics
seulement
ce ne sont pas une ou deux personnes
qu'ils vont assister à cette injure
publique à ce harcèlement public mais
des milliers voire même selon les cas
des millions avec des conséquences
dramatiques
d'autant que pour les jeunes filles par
exemple qui vont être à ce moment là
atteintes dans leur dignité avec des
images d'elle qu'ils vont être commentée
véhicule est stigmatisée étiqueté sur
les réseaux sociaux sans même ce qui a
été dit d'ailleurs tout à l'heure qu'il
y ait un minimum d'empathie à leur égard
sans même qu'on se demande à ce moment
là quelles sont les conséquences sur
leur personne d'autant que actuellement
on se préoccupe des sommes mises en
cause dans les situations de harcèlement
et ou de viols laissant encore une fois
les victimes deux côtés pensant
davantage à la réputation de ces hommes
qu'à celle des victimes ce que tu mets
au coeur joie là c'est la question du
genre la question du genre en tant que
le genre est un système ça a déjà été
dit
deux représentations de stéréotypes qui
se reproduisent qui s'accumulent qui
s'enracine mais c'est qu'il nous
intéresse aussi
c'est cette question du genre en tant
que le genre il est transformable en
tant que les rapports de genre ils sont
modifiables ils sont pliables
il y à du jeu j e u dans ces questions
de genre on peut les transformer et
c'est pour ça qu'on est là face à vous
aujourd'hui pour changer nos
représentations pour changer le réel
pour avoir une prise sur le réel pour
changer nos pratiques pour dire
également qu'il n'est plus possible de
voir des victimes de harcèlement et que
les témoins doivent agir alors en effet
les témoins de réagir parce que jusqu'à
présent avant que toutes ces femmes
dénonce de manière collective et
publique tous ces faits et bien avant ça
tout était su vue pour autant tu
maintenant on ne peut plus se taire
parce qu'on sait qu'on ait fait penser
que 10% des élèves victimes de
harcèlement à l'école le sont
principalement pour des raisons liées à
l'apparence physique au sexisme aux
questions de genre et que la moitié
d'entre eux sont victimes de harcèlement
excessivement sévères pouvant aller
jusqu'à des brimades physique
excessivement importante
on sait également que 100 % des femmes
entre 18 et 25 ans dans notre dernière
enquête ont été victimes de harcèlement
dans l'espace public durant les 12 mois
qui ont précédé cette enquête
on sait également que toute cette
banalisation des humiliations sexuelles
ou public va permettre également le aux
auteurs daljir en toute impunité en
toute impunité ne veut pas dire
forcément qu'ils ont conscience
nécessairement de leurs actes mais comme
ils n'ont jamais eu de rappel à l'ordre
qu'on ne leur a jamais dit vous nous
témoin pas une fois que ce n'était pas
normal et bien à ce moment là les choses
continuent on ne leur a pas dire on peut
dire maintenant que justement
collectivement que ce n'est pas normal
et donc par conséquent que ce n'est pas
acceptable
en d'autres termes dire que harceler
n'ai pas joué ce que tu mets au centre
de la sphère c'est la question des
témoins et d'ailleurs c'est notre
préoccupation principale des témoins
or on le sait là aussi et avec johanna
les enquêtes que l'on mène nous le
montre 87% des témoins de harcèlement ou
de violence dans les transports en
publics ne font rien alors tu vas me
dire 13% pour quelque chose
oui mais quand on regarde les 13% qui
font quelque chose qu'est ce qu'ils font
c'est 13% pour la moitié d'entre eux ils
augmentaient discrimination ils prennent
des photos ils prennent des vidéos ils
émettent sur les réseaux sociaux
il pointe du doigt la victime il rigole
en groupe ils n'interviennent pas pour
aider ils interviennent pour augmenter
l'opprobre et puis reste cette petite
moitié de 13% 5 6 7 % qui interviennent
pour aider la victime mais à une
condition
toujours à une seule condition c'est que
les violences soient paroxystique les
plus violentes les plus sanglantes les
plus nombreuses alors dire ça ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que lorsqu'il ya
pas de sens et des petites violences et
des violences du quotidien cd
microviolences c'est pas important
non ça aussi c'est des violences
l'injure la brimade le regard tout ça ça
correspond à de la violence
ça veut dire quoi également de dire que
87% des témoins ne font rien ça veut
dire que dans le paysage de la
discrimination et le harcèlement il n'y
a pas d'un côté les harceleurs et les
discriminant il n'y a pas de notre côté
les harceler et les discriminer non il y
a tout autour des témoins qui ont vu
qu'ils ont su et qui en rentrant chez
eux ou chez elles ont pu se dire
j'aurais dû intervenir
j'aurais pu intervenir et si on est là
face à vous c'est aussi et surtout pour
dire que c'était moins il faut les
concernés et il faut les sensibiliser
les sensibiliser parce que ces brimades
vont continuer bien au delà on le voit
avec le flot des témoignages qui
ressurgissent 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans après
pour autant on le voit j'en veux pour
preuve la question des school shooters
vous savez ces tireurs fous qui
reviennent dans les écoles pour tirer
sur tout ce qui bouge
parfois 10 15 ans également vingt ans
après et bien plus de 75% de ces school
shooters était victime de harcèlement à
l'école
il se retourne à ce moment-là contre une
institution qui n'a pas de suivre les
comprendre qui n'a pas vu justement
toute cette question de l'invisible
ibilité alors quand même joué à nat tous
les toutes les victimes ne sont pas des
scouts shooters
non on a beaucoup de victimes qui sont
plutôt dans l'évitement on l'a vu avec
les étudiantes dans nos enquêtes qui
évite la ville alors attention ça veut
pas dire qu'elles ne sont pas en ville
ça veut dire que elles vont en ville
avec des stratégies différentes
on a vu également que les victimes
avaient ce sentiment légitime de
paranoïa mais attention les victimes ne
sont pas paranoïaque au sens
psychiatrique du terme
elles sont paranoïaques parce que
personne n'est jamais venu à leur
secours
personne ne leur a jamais tendu la main
et puis il ya d'autres stratégies
il y a par exemple des stratégies telles
que l'évitement
on évite les espaces où les personnes
qui nous font mal il y à des stratégies
comme l'humour parfois comme dirait jane
birkin
mieux vaut en rire que d'être obligé
d'en pleurer et puis il ya des
stratégies collectives les stratégies
collectives comme ces associations
féministes qui lutte pour une meilleure
visibilité des femmes dans l'espace
public et dans les médias ou bien je
pense à l'association des journalistes
lgbt qui eux aussi milite pour une
meilleure visibilité des personnes lgbt
dans l'espace public et les médias
en tout cas si on avait un message à
faire passer ce soir c'est de vous
montrez vous en tant que témoin qu'il
est possible de faire quelque chose que
c'est à la fois une question de justice
mais également une question de justesse
on n'est pas que dans une logique
endroit mais bien dans une logique de
droits et puis également peut-être dire
qu'ici on n'est pas dans un tribunal qui
n'est pas question de juger ni de
trouver des coupables mais bien
d'avancer ensemble
et puis peut-être en finissant en se
posant cette question nous mêmes est-ce
que nous avons pas déjà nous même
employé ces mots qui font terriblement
mal en disant je suis pas un [ __ ] je suis
pas une [ __ ] qui également on n'a pas
vu des jeunes femmes ou plus âgées dans
la rue être interpellés pour des raisons
sexistes ou sexuelles on pourrait aussi
tout ensemble se poser une dernière
question qui est ce qui passe à ses mots
face à ces injures ces interpellations
qui stigmatisent a déjà agi est déjà
intervenu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]